[Music]
foreign
we heard it in a Hollywood movie Once a
million dollars isn't cool you know
what's cool a billion dollars and in
this town it's kind of true a movie
making minimum seven figures isn't cool
it's actually a box office bomb but 10
figures now we're talking cracking a
billion dollars globally requires a
mighty recipe of the hottest stars the
shiniest filmmaking technology and an
engaging plot with twists and turns that
never becomes super duper complicated
and of course you'll need an audience
willing to turn out in droves from
America to Lebanon to Zambia how about a
magic trick
foreign
I'm gonna make this pencil disappear
it's
so we've compiled all the movies that
have achieved just that and ranked them
by Tomato Meter it's a compelling window
into our era of Blockbusters and
inflation the last Lord of the Rings was
rewarded by fans with the highest gross
of the trilogy and then evaporated after
that the presence of the Star Wars movie
shows you can still ring plenty of money
out of a long in the tooth franchise and
then of course they're superheroes The
Dark Knight movies officially ushered an
era of big business for those who take
their comic book movie making seriously
Marvel took a lighter step focusing on
interconnected stories that create
serious fomo for those who Skip the
multiplex line in movies like Avengers
Spider-Man and Black Panther so I hope
you're ready to see some dollar signs as
we count down our picks of the best
billion dollar movies all ranked by
Tomato Meter
[Music]
number 10 Star Wars the Force awakens
30 years after the defeat of the
Galactic Empire the Galaxy faces a new
threat from the evil kylo Ren and the
first order when a Defector named Finn
crash lands on a desert Planet he meets
Rey a tough scavenger whose Droid
contains a top secret map together the
young Duo joins forces with Han Solo to
make sure the resistance receives the
intelligence concerning the whereabouts
of Luke Skywalker the last of the Jedi
Knights starring Harrison Ford Mark
Hamill Carrie Fisher and directed by JJ
Abrams critics say packed with action
and populated by both familiar faces and
fresh blood the force awakens
successfully recalls the series his
former glory while injecting it with
Renewed Energy
stop it
[Music]
the garbage will do
the positions down there
you ever fly this day
this ship hasn't thrown in years
number nine Finding Dory Dory is a
wide-eyed blue tank fish who suffers
from memory loss every 10 seconds or so
the one thing she can remember is that
she somehow became separated from her
parents as a child with help from her
friends Nemo and Marlon Dorian barks on
an epic adventure to find them her
journey brings her to the marine life
Institute a conservatory that houses
diverse ocean species Dory now knows
that her family reunion will only happen
if she can save mom and dad from
captivity starring Ellen DeGeneres
Albert Brooks Ed O'Neill and directed by
Andrew Stanton critics say funny
poignant and thought-provoking Finding
Dory delivers a beautifully animated
Adventure that adds another entertaining
chapter to its predecessors classic
story I suffer from short-term memory
loss
that's exactly what you say
you want to play hide and seek okay
we'll hide and you count and come find
us okay Daddy no no not daddy I'm the
nice fish who wants to be your friend
okay okay Daddy no I'm hiding now count
to ten
one two three
four
play with them number eight The Dark
Knight
with the help of allies Lieutenant Jim
Gordon and D.A Harvey Dent Batman has
been able to keep a tight lid on crime
in Gotham City but what a vile young
criminal calling himself The Joker
suddenly throws a town into chaos the
Caped Crusader begins to try to fine
line between heroism and vigilantism
starring Christian Bale Heath Ledger
Aaron Eckhart and directed by
Christopher Nolan critics say dark
complex and Unforgettable The Dark
Knight succeeds not just as an
entertaining comic book film but as a
richly thrilling crime Saga
oh you want to play come on
[Music]
he missed
you can't stop you're like
ducks
[Music]
thank you
I don't want you to do it come on
number seven Avengers end game a drift
in space with no food or water Tony
Stark sends a message to Pepper Potts as
his oxygen supply starts to dwindle
meanwhile the remaining Avengers Thor
Black Widow Captain America and Bruce
Banner must figure out a way to bring
back their vanquished allies for an epic
showdown with Thanos the evil demigod
who decimated the planet and the
universe starring Robert Downey Jr Chris
Evans Mark Ruffalo and directed by
Anthony and Joe Russo critics say
exciting entertaining and emotionally
impactful Avengers end game does
whatever it takes to deliver a
satisfying finale to Marvel's epic
Infinity Saga
thought by eliminating half of life
the other half of thrive
but you've shown me
that's impossible
and as long as there are those that
remember what was there will always be
those that are unable to accept what can
be
resist
yep we're all kinds of stubborn
thankful
because now
I know what I must do
I will
shred this universe down to its last
atom
and then
with the stones you've collected for me
create a new one
teeming with life
that knows not what it is lost but only
what it has been given
[Music]
a grateful Universe born out of blood
they'll never know it
because you won't be alive to tell them
number six Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows part two
a clash between good and evil awaits as
young Harry Ron and Hermione prepare for
a final battle against Lord Voldemort
Harry has grown into a seedly lad on a
mission to rid the world of evil the
friends must search for the horcruxes
that keep the disasterly wizard Immortal
Harry and Voldemort meet at Hogwarts
Castle for an epic showdown where the
forces of Darkness May finally meet
their match starring Daniel Radcliffe
Rupert Grint Emma Watson and directed by
David Yates
critics say thrilling powerfully acted
and Visually dazzling Deathly Hallows
Part 2 brings the Harry Potter franchise
to a satisfying and suitably magical
conclusion
foreign
[Music]
what brings you here Potter
could ask you the same
you have something of mine
I'd like it back what's wrong with the
one you have it's my mother's
it's powerful but it's
not the same
doesn't quite
understand me
know what I mean
why didn't you tell her
Bellatrix
you news me
you didn't say anything
don't be a brat
to him
easy
number five black panther after the
death of his father t'challa returns
home to the African nation of wakanda to
take his rightful place as king when a
powerful enemy suddenly reappears
t'challa's medal is King and his black
panther gets tested when he's drawn into
a conflict that puts the fate of wakanda
in the entire world at risk faced with
treachery and danger the young king must
rally his allies and release the full
power of black panther to defeat his
foes and secure the safety of his people
starring Chadwick Boseman Michael B
Jordan Lupita Nyong'o and directed by
Ryan coogler critics say black panther
elevates superhero Cinema to thrilling
New Heights while telling one of the
mcu's most absorbing stories and
introducing some of its most fully
realized characters
[Music]
thank you
let the challenge
begin
oh my God
number four top gun Maverick
after more than 30 years of service as
one of the Navy's top aviators Pete
Maverick Mitchell is where he belongs
pushing the envelope as a courageous
test pilot and dodging the advancement
in rank that would ground him when he
finds himself training a Detachment of
Top Gun graduates for a specialized
Mission the likes of which no living
pilot has ever seen Maverick encounters
Lieutenant Bradley Bradshaw call sign
rooster the son of Maverick's late
friend and radar intercept officer
Lieutenant Nick Bradshaw AKA Goose
facing an uncertain future and
confronting the ghosts of his past
Maverick is drawn into a confrontation
with his own deepest fears culminating
in a mission that demands the ultimate
sacrifice from those who will be chosen
to fly it starring Tom Cruise Miles
Teller Jennifer Connelly and directed by
Joseph Kaczynski critics say top gun
Maverick pulls off a feat even trickier
than a 4G inverted dive delivering a
long-related sequel that surpasses its
predecessor in wildly inner retaining
style you with me right behind you
standby should pop up strike dagger 3 in
position
foreign
I've got it got a capture Target
acquired Bob's awake
number three Toy Story 4. Woody Buzz
Lightyear and the rest of the gang
embark on a road trip with Bonnie and a
new toy named Forkey The Adventurous
Journey turns into an unexpected reunion
as Woody slight detour leads him to his
long-lost friend Bo Peep as Woody and
Beau discuss the old days they soon
start to realize that their worlds apart
when it comes to what they want from
Life as a toy starring Tom Hanks Tim
Allen Annie Potts and directed by Josh
Cooley critics say heartwarming funny
and beautifully animated Toy Story 4
manages the unlikely feat of extending
and perhaps concluding a Practically
Perfect animated Saga
go
flashlight
[Music]
hang on our seats
I ain't got people to sleep
[Music]
number two zootopia from the largest
elephant to the smallest shrew the city
of zootopia is a mammal Metropolis where
various animals live and Thrive when
Judy Hopps becomes the first rabbit to
join the police force she quickly learns
how tough it is to enforce the law
determined to prove herself Judy jumps
at the opportunity to solve a mysterious
case unfortunately that means working
with Nick Wilde a wiley Fox who makes
her job even harder starring Jennifer
Goodwin Jason Bateman Shakira and
directed by Byron Howard and Rich Moore
critics say the brilliantly well-rounded
zootopia offers a thoughtful inclusive
message that's as rich and timely as it
is sumptuously state-of-the-art
animation all while remaining fast and
funny enough to keep younger viewers
entertained
that's good for you has 12 unique
ecosystems within its city limits
Sahara Square rainforest District to
name a few you're gonna have to master
all of them before you hit the streets
oh guess what you'll be dead
the sandstorm
You're Dead Bunny pumpkin
You're Dead characters
come on girl
enormous Criminal
dead
you're dead fluff butt
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
Spider-Man no way home for the first
time in the Cinematic history of
Spider-Man our friendly neighborhood
Heroes identity is revealed bringing his
superhero responsibilities into conflict
with his normal life and putting those
he cares about most at risk when he
enlists Doctor Strange's help to restore
his secret the spell tears a hole in
their world releasing the most powerful
villains who've ever fought a Spider-Man
in any Universe now Peter will have to
overcome his greatest challenge yet
which will not only forever alter his
own future but the future of the
Multiverse starring Tom Holland Zendaya
Benedict Cumberbatch and directed by
John Watts critics say a bigger Bolder
Spider-Man sequel no way home expands
the franchise's scope and states without
losing sight of its humor and heart give
me the Box
huh
[Music]
what is this place it's a mirror
Dimension where I'm in control
can we please just talk about this
marker don't you realize that in the
Multiverse there are an infinite number
of people who know Peter Parker is
Spider-Man and if that spell gets loose
they're all coming here look I know I
get it but we can't just send them home
to die it's their faith
can't change that any more than you can
change who they are
oh what are you doing
the Lord of the Rings The Return of the
King the culmination of nearly 10 years
work and conclusion at Peter Jackson's
epic Trilogy based on the Timeless J.R.R
Tolkien classic presents the final
confrontation between the forces of Good
and Evil fighting for control of the
future of Middle Earth Hobbits Frodo and
Sam reach Mordor in their quest to
destroy the one ring while Aragorn leads
the forces of good against sauron's evil
Army at the Stone City of Minas tirith
starring Elijah Wood Ian McKellen Viggo
Mortensen and directed by Peter Jackson
critics say visually breathtaking and
emotionally powerful the Lord of the
Rings The Return of the King is a moving
and satisfying conclusion to a great
trilogy
Underground
my brothers
I see in your eyes
the same fear that would take the heart
of me
a day may come when the courage of men
fails when we forsake our friends and
break all bonds of Fellowship but it is
not this day
an hour of wolves and shattered Shields
when the age of men comes crashing down
but it is not this day this day we fight
by all that you hold dear on this
scooter I bid you stand
Man of the West
Avatar
on the Lush alien world of Pandora live
the navi beings who appear primitive but
are highly evolved because the planet's
environment is poisonous human Navi
hybrids called avatars must link to
human Minds to allow for free movement
on Pandora Jake Sully a paralyzed former
Marine becomes mobile again through one
such Avatar and falls in love with a
navi Woman as a bond with her grows he's
drawn into a battle for the survival of
her world starring Sam Worthington Zoe
Saldana Sigourney Weaver and directed by
James Cameron critics say it might be
more impressive on a technical level
than as a piece of Storytelling but
Avatar reaffirms James Cameron's
singular gift for imaginative absorbing
filmmaking
First Flight seals the bond you cannot
wait
fly
[Music]
[Applause]
shut up and fly straight
that's it Bank left
level out listen
and finally number one Toy Story three
with their beloved Andy preparing to
leave for college Woody Buzz Lightyear
Jessie and the rest of the toys find
themselves headed for the attic but
mistakenly wind up on the curb with the
trash Woody's quick thinking saves the
gang but all but would he end up being
donated to a daycare center
unfortunately the uncontrollable kids do
not play nice so Woody and the Gang make
plans for a Great Escape starring Tom
Hanks Tim Allen Joan Cusack and directed
by Lee Anchorage critics say definitely
blending comedy adventure and honest
emotion Toy Story 3 is a rare second
sequel that really works play real play
I can't wait oh speaking of play time
they're lining up out there how many
there must be dozens I can hardly wait
places everyone
[Music]
I'm gonna get played with uh Rex Come to
Papa
[Music]
well my friends that about does it for
us be sure to stay tuned to the Rotten
Tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love until
next time I'm your host Naz Perez and
we'll see you back here for more top
tens on the Rotten Tomatoes countdown
[Music]
thank you